psychic defense for fully up to even
engage with this drama to engage with
any of the discussion around it. Yeah,
Todd's an auntie. Chod's an auntie. Oh
my god. Oh, the oddly specific things
and stuff. Oh, it was just Oh my god.
What the [__] are you saying? Why can
you not stammer out a single coherent
point, make his own lane by um making
videos where he regurgitates what
Nicholas Durio says on his streams? So
yeah, let's give this a go. So C Samron
F305,
alleged child rapist, called into Mama
Oo's
live stream to discuss the Turkey Tom
allegations last night. And from what I
saw, it's about as embarrassing as every
other appearance Cameron F5 has had on
the live stream. Uh cuz this guy's like
[__] disabled. Like genuinely. Um
totally worthless, incapable of original
thought, can't even reason through other
people's opinions.
and is a total creep [__]
just weirdo, dude. Like every mannerism
this guy has just says disabled pervert.
>> So, let's take a look. Let's see.
>> Yes, it's perfect way to start. It's
very autistic,
>> you know, manufacturing purposes
>> for sure.
>> And then then they had to be shipped to
the United States for distribution. It
was a whole mess.
>> Oh, sorry. There's Morocco, but like I
mean I don't even need to I thought we
don't I don't even need to introduce
Morocco. You get the idea pretty
quickly.
>> Imagine. So France, is there a specific
reason why they did it in France?
>> It was just a French company.
>> Oh, fair enough. Fair enough. Fair
enough. Actually
>> price was really good.
>> No, I would imagine so. Probably. Yeah.
>> Per unit. And then uh they sent me a
hundred extra which is still being sold
today
to this day. Yeah. So So 300 units were
made in total.
>> So it it's like And I'm assuming that's
like your music that was made, right?
>> Yes. Which was [__] awesome.
>> Yeah.
>> At the time. I just wish it wasn't for
what it was for. But I mean
>> No, I I I that's fair.
>> That's fair. But still it is kind of
neat to just say
>> I'm I'm still No, I know it is so neat.
I still like I regardless of what it was
for, I'm still like really proud of
that.
>> Yeah. No. Yeah.
>> Uh it's one of my one of my uh most
proud achievements. [snorts]
>> Yeah. I I would say not many people can
say I've had my stuff put on a vinyl
before.
>> I know. I That made me really happy and
I love saying it to people. That's why
I'm talking about it.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
Oh goodness. Yeah. No, that's totally I
I think like being able to create that
kind of stuff is it is like a an oddly
good feeling right now. Um
>> yeah,
>> you know,
>> I would love to sell like a custom like
cop outfit or something like that.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh something high quality, higher
quality than the actual one I wear in
videos [laughter]
>> cuz that would [__] suck.
>> That [snorts] would be funny.
>> I have like three because
The first one's button immediately
broke. Like the top button broke.
>> So I I got a backup and then that one
had a [__] up hat. So I'm like I need
I need a few backups.
>> Yeah.
>> So I have three different Content Cop
outfits.
>> Where did you go like go to the Spirit
of Halloween in order to get them?
[laughter]
>> No. I I you I had to order from uh from
a [__] shady website. They were out
of the money.
>> Who's skipping?
>> Uh I dressed up as Hassan.
>> Uhhuh.
I I doubt it.
>> You doubt it?
>> I think um I think they're in it for the
long haul. Although I don't doubt
they're having marriage problems.
>> He says, "Okay, [__] hell."
>> Exhausted.
>> I we ever since
>> 52
>> anime, they have no idea what they're
plugged. You should get plugged up.
[laughter]
>> Oh, I'm not quite sure what that mean
about.
>> Um I
I'll ask a you plugged up. I'm plugged
up.
>> I'm not quite sure.
>> I'm not quite sure what that means.
>> You should get plugged up. You should
get plugged up. [laughter]
>> The lord behind that is one of the in uh
>> put this guy in prison.
>> The chicks I think it was one of the
chicks who like said crazy [__] about me
claimed that I that I was embarrassed or
like one of the blackmail that she
apparently had over me was that I use a
butt plug which is made up. And I
thought that was really funny.
>> Okay. I I mean like
>> and Inut broke that news to me and he's
he started asking me if I was plugged up
and that's just been kind of a running
gag between me and him cuz I think
that's really funny.
>> That's fair. I I will say you know I
don't uh gag really interested in
talking about uh [laughter] toys of that
nature. You know, you know, you know, I
I will say I will say um you know what
we're going to what we'll talk about
with Tom is definitely
>> degenerate.
We're entering plugged up territory.
>> Oh gosh. Maybe. Maybe. But like what
I'll say is just like [laughter]
um
>> is he really doing that [__] H3 [__]
dude? Oh,
>> I hope it's Skype.
>> I I have too much shame to want to talk
about that kind of [__] I'm not really
interested in like in that, you know.
[laughter]
not a not a plugged up guy. You're just
not a plugged up guy.
>> I I I
>> That's all right.
>> Yeah. You know what?
>> And that's okay.
>> If
>> it's not for everyone.
>> If if my future wife, you know, I have
no idea. She'll really have to convince
me. But uh for right now, I'm going to
say probably not.
>> Probably not. You know,
>> that shit's gay.
>> But as a gay man, I think that's dope.
>> Oh gosh. Okay. You know, speaking of
gay,
>> these are Turkey Tom shooters. Now these
are the Turkey Tom and Nick Dioro
shooters. Now
>> really quickly as a
>> actually speaking which wait I'll play
the max post. It's funny.
>> This hit this hit for me. I felt seen by
this
man. Wait, so bad.
>> This is
side tangent. You know Caleb Hammer,
right?
>> Of course.
>> Okay. Did you know that he he is
admitted on camera? He's like 10% gay.
>> What the [__] [laughter] Yeah, I so I
covered the so um somebody made some
videos uh talking about allegations of
his and like um he like when talking to
somebody said I'm not cuz he was like oh
I'm I want to uh hook you up with this
escort service cuz it sounds like that's
what you want to do. [music] And like
the guy that he was trying to hook up
like didn't want to do gay but like
Caleb was like oh there's this guy that
will do gay. And Caleb was like I'm not
really into that kind of stuff but I'm
pretty sure I'm like 10% gay. And and
I'm just sitting there like, "Man, if
you're 10% gay, that [laughter]
>> Well, I think he mentioned like, oh, I
have to get drunk or something like
that. And I was like, okay, okay, okay,
okay. As there's a there's a couple of
extra steps in there, and it's just
like, okay. [laughter]
I just I just feel like that that
requires a desire, that requires an
attraction. Although, I have heard like
the the uh the saying that any every
straight man would have sex with Ryan
Reynolds, and I think that's fair.
I don't know. Huh? He's not really that
interesting to me. I Here, chat. We'll
I'll pull up a picture.
>> There was a time and a place. There was
a time and a place.
>> Which version of Ryan Reynolds are we
talking about?
>> Definitely not Deadpool.
>> Definitely not Deadpool. No, that one is
definitely
>> Holy Reddit.
>> You know that movie where he played like
a game character? I think it was like
Freeman. I think
>> Free Guy. Free.
>> Yeah, Free Guy. That was a good one.
[laughter]
Look at Ryan
very
>> mama aa with
>> let's get to the Tom talk to
>> talk about this on my stream I didn't I
and I kind but I also kind of want to
rant about it which is why I'm glad
we're having this background
>> because I put an announcement on my
discord about this saying
>> uh after getting a [__] ton of DMs
asking me to stream about it saying no I
don't I won't cover unverified
information from two seemingly
disgruntled exes on stream all quote
unquote evidence is weird leaked private
text that don't really say much. If
there's something substant substantive
that's of public interest, I'll cover
it. This isn't the case from what I've
seen here.
>> Yeah.
>> With that said, the final main channel
stream is on first Saturday, which is
tomorrow at around 6 or 7.
>> If there's something substantive of
public interest, I'll cover it.
Doesn't this guy obsess over? He was
just talking about [__] Idubbbz and's
marriage, dude.
And now all of a sudden you care. You
only care about substantive matters of
public interest
when you sit there literally picking
apart every [__] detail of Idol's
marriage.
>> Time be there. Be square.
>> Drop the
square. Um h and then I said uh TLDDR
stay away from BPD chicks.
>> I mean that's a very fair thing to say.
I'm going to be completely honest with
you. Um for those that need like a brief
understanding of what
>> crazy [__] am I right? Crazy
[__] Am I right?
>> This is the thing, man. This is I'm like
I'm just fried. I'm like fried or
something, bro.
I've seen I've seen through it,
unfortunately. I've seen through it.
It's too late for me. I can't listen to
people instantly start talking about how
women bleed if you've got a big dick and
stay away from crazy [__] I
literally It makes me want to opt out of
everything.
It makes me feel so [__] just mad.
It's so gay.
And it it feels like that every way of
calling it out
is like you have to stab yourself at the
same time.
>> Girls who have been verified by the
owner of the farms as as real people
joined and started alleging all of these
things when they were in some form of
relationship with Turkey Tom. And a lot
of the stuff that they alleged, like as
far as I know, none of it was like
hinging on illegal territory. It was
really just like uh
>> there was one we the only concerning one
for me was the age play thing.
>> Well, that what's funny about that one
is I
>> I don't believe that's true. I think
he's like that's just like a joke. That
sounds like some stream joke he would
make.
>> It's so this is as well.
>> I'm having to listen to people saying do
really worries me is that Tom might be
into age play.
Uh,
>> well, the thing is I don't even think he
would be the one into it. I just think
that he dated a I just think he dated a
woman that unironically
>> Yeah, literally is not this bad in the
real world. It's just not this bad in
the real world, man. It's like
>> turned out to be that way. Yeah. Or he
flirted with a chick that that had that
or something like that.
>> Yeah. It's just funny because like um
and some somebody pointed out it's just
like he's talked about age play stuff in
the past and then they're like oh but
why did he date somebody like that just
like I I' I'd be curious to know if he
know knew about it. Probably did because
like she had an Instagram where she
apparently posted a lot of this stuff
but
>> maybe but it it depends on what your
definition of age play is. People think
Bel Deline is age play which I don't
really know if that's the case
>> really. They think Bel Why? I mean,
that's like the whole point of this like
thing is like because she was a Bel
Deline type chick who does age play and
I'm like, well, do you mean Bel Deline
who does age play or this chick who's
like Bel Deline does age play?
>> That makes no sense because Bel Deli is
it because she's small and petite.
>> It's like I I don't think she could help
that part.
>> Yeah, it's just like I know a lot of
women who are are like they're not tall.
Dude, this is like the [__] lollycon
[__] isn't it?
Where they're like um you know the these
like uh petite women will cosplay child
characters and do like
NSFW photo shoots and then they'll go
like and play, you know, it's like,
yeah, you want to do that, you want to
do that, whatever. But then they go and
play dumb and they're like, oh, I'm just
I'm just petite. What? you can't be
petite and do porn anymore and all this
stupid [__] And then they do it with
like the Lolly Vtubers as well where
they're like, "Oh, she just uses a lolly
Vtuber cuz she's like really really
small in real life." It's like, "Dude,
stop the cap. Stop the cap.
This is insane. You're talking crazy
right now." I feel like I should pull
this up. I should pull up should move
edit just for the sake of having the
evidence here while we're discussing it.
[__] sake. Wait, wait, wait. Not
working. Okay.
>> All I know is Tom has a big dick.
>> I watched Nick's stream and he's just
talking about how Tom has a big hairy
dick.
>> Hippie hoarder Shirusa girl he sent dick
pics to and got hacked was an age play
Beline type girl.
My diaper. I got a
>> Get away from me.
>> I got a
>> It's just It's crazy.
>> It's crazy.
>> You can't say it's age play if if
they're tiny. I I I don't know. That's
That sounds like a retail. That's why
people saying I thought that like the
woman actually did some form of age
play, but you know, I I it's weird, you
know, do what you do what you want to
do. Uh and people are allowed to
ridicule you for it, but like um I I
just thought it was funny that like Tom
was quote unquote caught dating somebody
like that.
>> Yeah. Well, I I think the age played
chick he never dated or like he was
going to get flirting with this chick
and like maybe had sex with her or
something and then she started
blackmailing his dickpicks is what I
understand.
>> Yeah. Well, what's funny is
>> this guy just has the story completely
wrong. It's quite baffling.
>> You bring up the blackmail. Uh some
people are are saying that like
>> Sorry. Uh some people are saying that
like he doesn't think it's her, but it's
just like buddy, come on now. It's
always going to be the woman or uh the
guy that's secretly dating the woman, if
that makes sense.
>> Right.
>> Uh especially when they know you got a
lot of money,
>> right? No. Um,
but I I think the the real like [__]
thing that came out of this like
immediately which I guess sparked some
like pent up frustration from when I
what I was going through.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Was seeing these
>> Yeah. This whole drama is just like
cognto hazard.
It's like gen genuinely you need like
psychic defense for fully up to even
engage with this drama to engage with
any of the discussion around it.
[laughter] It's like genuinely so many
streams like sent shivers down my spine
listening to people talk about this
[__] retards. Like, and by the way, I
I've been one to like [clears throat]
somewhat defend one of these retards in
the past, but honestly, [__] this guy.
I'm going to Defcon 3. [__] Chud
Logic. [__] Smaggle Daggle. [__] that
guy especially. And Auggie just all
jumping. Augie's like, "Oh, I I guess me
and Nicholas Dior are the only ones
left." But you're not even in the
conversation. Nobody watches you
anymore.
>> Blackmail.
>> Thank you for the $5. defend one of
these retards in the past. And by the
way, I I've been one to like somewhat
defend that I was going through.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Was seeing these [__] retards like
And by the way, I I've been one to like
somewhat defend one of these retards in
the past, but honestly, [__] this guy.
I'm going to Defcon 3. [__] Chud
Logic. [__] Smaggle Daggle. [__] that
guy especially. And Auggie just all
jumping. Augie's like, "Oh, I I guess me
and Nicholas Dior are the only ones
left." Buddy, you're not even in the
conversation. Nobody watches you
anymore.
>> Wait,
>> dude. Augie gets like what? What do they
have on kick the other? 1.5K
on kick.
You know how much money that is on KCIP,
bro? That's That's a nice little bit of
cash. Okay, that's a nice little bit of
cash. Or rapes you, bro. Ouggie legit
like, you know, Ogie rapes this guy.
Oh, he's mad cuz Ouggie covered his
allegations.
Dude, that's it, isn't it? Cuz uh we got
we get to cover the camera and stuff and
he was like, "Yeah, this guy's fucked."
Oh, I see. I see.
Especially and Auggie just all jumping.
Augie's like, "Oh, I I guess me and
Nicholas Dior are the only ones left."
Buddy, you're not even in the
conversation. Nobody watches you
anymore.
>> Wait, what are you talking about,
Auggie?
>> Is that something he said on Twitter?
I'm I'm curious.
>> He made a tweet. He's like, "Oh, looks
like it's just me and Dioro nowadays."
Shut up.
>> What's funny about Augie? Doesn't even
stream anymore. Doesn't he have like do
real life now? He just like focuses on
real life. I'm confused.
>> No, he streams on kick now. Does
>> he stream on kick? He only streams on
Well, no. I stopped paying attention to
him when he left YouTube. Why did he go
straight to
>> my point prove it?
>> Like I [laughter]
>> I listened to RFC after hours.
>> So did I.
>> When it was him, Boax, occasionally
Dioro, and then other people. And then
like I just like slowly drifted off of
it because you know he went and got a
real life
>> and
>> and I respected him and then he came
back and he was doing like RFC mania or
whatever the [__] when he came back and
then he which is when he I think
officially denounced me or something. He
said I was excommunicated.
>> Excommunicate. Dude, this guy is so
disabled.
Dude,
why don't people call this out? Why do
people like Cameron get to walk around
and think that they do not have
something wrong with them? I don't
understand. I don't understand. Am I the
only one who can pick up on
like mental disabilities and
neurological issues and am I the only
one who's saying it? Like you you don't
say this much [__] [__] without
having something wrong with you.
You endlessly [__] up phrases. You don't
know any words. You're like you have
these bizarre mouth movements. Your
behavior is insane. You've got like
severe arrested development. Like
there's something wrong with you. I
don't understand how other people don't
see this and point it out.
We should not let people like Cameron go
around thinking they're like normal
people like the rest of us. And I mean
he he's got to be acutely aware because
he's on the stream talking to Morocco.
Uh and then I got 60,000 more
subscribers after that. I know it sounds
egotistical to saying you're not
supposed to say it, but like it's just
funny to me because he didn't do an inch
of research into me and then tried
[__] with me. Now be granted when he
got banned from YouTube I was supportive
because like
>> obviously I don't want him to be
censored or anything,
>> right? No. Yeah, you can.
>> Now this is a new term to me. I don't
hate the guy. I think he can be chill. I
used to love his show, but I think
nowadays like the
>> a breach baby is a baby lying bottom
first or feet first in the uterus or
womb instead of in the usual head first
position. NHS, what happens if your baby
is breach? Okay.
>> Like you can't have that ego if you've
quit for years.
>> That is really interesting cuz So like
is he like
So he's on kick now. Is it like
fulltime? He's streaming uh multiple
nights a week now.
>> He said he got like the same numbers
because he was banned on YouTube. He
doesn't want to risk it again. So, he
only posts like his highlights.
>> Why doesn't he just do it like Medicare
and just like record do a stream on
YouTube and then somebody else will
reupload it somewhere else? That makes
no sense.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. You know, if that's what he wants
to do.
>> Now, as for Smaggle, so Smaggle, I don't
know. Uh, I don't know what the [__]
happened to this guy.
>> I know little about Smaggle. He's just a
name that I know of mentioned all the
time.
>> See, Smaggle I can have respect for cuz
he knows he's kind of [__] and rolls
with it. Okay, Cameron, I simply can't I
simply cannot respect someone that
doesn't know they're [__]
>> in the commentary sphere.
>> Well, the reason for that is because
>> smaggal is a fed.
>> Uh, and I'm going to pull up a Twitter
thread for you.
>> Oh, boy.
>> I'll send it to you. Uh, the reason is
because he's like the moderator. He was
moderator for Tom Dark's live stream.
He's the moderator for Nick Dioro's
Discord and stream. Uh, he just kind of
has always been that guy. And apparently
he's also like he also makes videos or
whatever.
>> Yeah,
>> but that part I I don't really care
about the wool agent smaggle.
>> And um a former Janney or is he still a
Janney?
>> He's still Nick's like main mod.
And yet he's so antagonistic and
[__]
>> that I don't understand why. I'll be
honest, Smaggle. Smaggle's kind of a
Excuse me. But he is my one for the
stream.
>> Sorry.
>> Uh like he's just such a [__] [__]
>> Uhhuh.
>> Uh and you're not supposed to say that
the language retards talking crazy.
>> Hours the other one. hours [laughter]
after um that this news drops right
after Nick ends his stream, which it was
breaking as Nick was streaming.
>> Yes.
>> Smaggle responds with this uh elephant
>> with the the elephant in the room, the
tweet I just sent you.
>> Yeah, here I post. I'm It's I'm stream.
Well, I'm I got it up.
>> The Nick Andrews uh reply was [__]
perfect, right? Like why did you not
pivot your whole stream to platform?
>> Dude, the Nandros tweet is not perfect
because Nandros typed out a [__]
essay over smaggle posting [__]
address the elephant meme.
Nandros is literally [__] tap
dancing, shucking and jing like, "Oh,
mass massic. Massan."
It's cringe as hell. Smaggle's just
proddding him and the cand is like get
down, Mr. President. You know, it's like
it's not life or death, bro. You don't
have to jump in here.
>> Perfect. Right. Like, why did you not
pivot your whole stream to platform
unverified information? Exactly. freshly
dropped onto a notorious gossip doxing
website
>> about your longtime friend before you
even know if it's in the public interest
or just embarrassing stuffful X has to
uh has leaked to humiliate them. Have a
little patience, Ninja.
>> No, I agree. No, I 100% agree. Um it
reminds It's really funny because like
um you know I I cover
>> something Jim is totally washed. Jim is
washed.
I don't even think about the VTuber [__]
anymore or any gay [__] like that after
he broke down crying about Charlie Kug
dying and said he was Christian now.
Sorry. That's just like you're you're
done. And sometimes, you know, people
will try and stir up things about around
me. Like last year there were a couple
YouTubers who did stupid [__] that like
were trying to get my attention and it
and people are just like, "Oh, why don't
you talk about your drum?" And it's just
like uh cuz I want it to go away.
>> Exactly. [laughter]
And if it's not worth like talking
about, I'm not going to talk about it.
Cuz the number one thing that drama
creators will tell you is if it's not
important or you're not like a predator,
you don't need to talk about it and you
just need to let it go away. And so Nick
is like, even though I don't always
agree with Nick on everything, I think
that Nick is making the smart choice to
be like, "Oh [__] there's this thing
that I'd like to figure out." So he
probably like stop it, I think, as we
speak.
>> Yeah, he was watched for a while,
Frigles, but it just that that was like
irredeemable. It's just like so [__]
cringe.
It's It's one thing to kind of lose your
touch when you're on the way out. It's
another thing to just totally embarrass
yourself by that
>> covering it covering it tonight. And
it's just like I don't blame him for
being like I I can't talk about it right
now because
>> I didn't think he wanted to. I don't
even think he wants to cover this. I
think he's being like kind of forced to.
And I don't blame him for not wanting to
cover it because even Chudogic said it
and he hopped on this and he's enjoying
this so much. He said that there isn't
really any reliable evidence here
>> or uh verifiable information
looking good.
>> Yeah.
>> He admits he admits that he's just like
compromised, right? Like he's
compromised for like platforming.
>> How is that compromised?
If you cover the allegation and say
there's not enough to prove the claims,
how is that compromised? Like this is
the sweep. This is like a new standard
for Tom only.
You can cover any false allegations
except the ones against us.
I mean, not even I don't even mean to
call them false there, but you know what
I mean. You understand what I'm saying?
unsubstantiated, not fully proven,
whatever it be.
>> And treating them as as if they're
substantive.
>> As if they're sub. Yeah. I Okay. That I
don't really like that because it's just
like, yeah, I cover drama and it's fun
to cover drama because like it it's it's
a fun thing, you know? I always like to
>> sense is like Chud Chud's always been a
bit of an antie. He's always been a bit
of like an antie, dude. An auntie. See,
you can see this guy's from like anime
[__] lollycon [__] communities,
bro. Yeah, Chad's an auntie. Chad's an
auntie.
An [__] But but it was funny and it
was it worked because it it seemed like
there was a little bit of prejudice
equality.
>> I feel like that's just gone now. He's
just totally like
uh
duplicitous.
>> I don't know. He is a Brit Bong. And uh
I have like a rule about Brit Bongs. Uh
all of them are uh get the same level of
treatment from me, especially after
seeing that.
>> This coming from the man who is in BBC
like BMW servers and represents
themselves as a as a brown octopus woman
online
>> uh that you can play in the UK. I think
it's UK. The one where you like uh
>> Oh yeah, they literally sit here talking
about this. Guys, is there anything to
actually be upset about with this
Pathways propaganda game? I've only I
literally like
this is the this was so true. I saw this
earlier on Twitter.
I saw for the first time like a liberal
or left-leaning person engage with one
of the posts about Pathways and they
were just like, "How sad is it that
right-wingers will liter just sit there
jerking themselves off about this anime
girl they've thought up thinking they're
like owning the libs by just sitting
around sharing porn basically." And
that's just so true. I have not seen all
the only engagement with this Pathway
[__] I've seen is right-wingers jerking
themselves off about it. So, Pathways is
like this
borderline flash game like shovelware
[__] that's like this anti-extremism
game funded by the UK government that's
like, "Oh, be careful about extremism
online." This sort of [__] It's like a
PSA in game format.
like the sort of thing you would show in
school to kids and right-wingers have
just been like I don't know spazzing out
about it like the whole last week and a
half. Yeah, I've barely looked into it
but there's like a
purplehaired corporate art girl
character and they they use like AI to
make an anime version and they're like,
"Oh yeah, she's like a nationalist icon
now." And they all just sit around
jerking off to her and that's it.
And that's like their whole engagement
of it for the last week and a half. It's
that whole engagement for everything
basically at this point.
>> Best ending is like you get arrested
like that. Especially after that I'm
just like I don't know man. I I do kind
of feel like
>> you get re-educated. You get the
re-education camp.
>> Yeah. It's just like I don't know. I
don't really care about uh those their
opinions.
>> Like a parody. I thought it Charlie. It
was not good. They went to re-education
camp and they fixed Charlie.
>> That was really funny. Uh I just like
that the best the best answers were so
that you could get with the hot girl
that was like talking about like um
>> uh British values and taking uh taking
your uh taking your country back. It was
funny. [laughter]
>> They took it down. They took down the
game.
>> They took it down briefly and then put
put it back up.
>> There was a brief period. But what's
funny is there was a brief period where
if you chose all the wrong answers,
allegedly, I don't know how true this
is, but I I'll trust the the internet
for this just based off of how funny it
was, but allegedly if uh you answered
all of the questions wrong, they would
say, "We're reporting you to the police
for uh for all of these answers you
gave."
>> Wasn't it made for children?
>> I think it's meant for just people in
general. I don't know.
It It looks like It looks like uh little
Timmy's first video game type beat.
>> It's like It's like a PSA.
>> It's just like a PSA in another format.
They're all spazzing out over nothing.
>> Choose your own adventure kind of thing
where you have to choose to uh choose to
not be bigoted and racist towards uh
people coming into your country.
[laughter]
[gasps]
>> I dude like the the oddly specific
things and stuff. It was just oh my
gosh.
>> Wow. That that was very articulate,
Cameron. Very very articulate point
there, Cameron, I must say. Sorry. What
was that?
>> Choose to not be bigoted and racist
towards uh people coming into your
country.
>> I dude like the the oddly specific
things and stuff. It was just Oh my god.
>> Oh, the oddly specific things and stuff.
Oh, it was just Oh my god. What the [__]
are you saying?
What the [__] are you saying? Why are
you so dented? Why can you not stammer
out a single coherent point? Seriously,
this is what I mean. We let people like
this operate as if they're equals to
everyone else. They're not.
They're not. There's something wrong
with him.
>> Gosh, it was funny. It's like and you
could have values like to say, "Hey,
this kind of stuff isn't cool while also
acknowledging that this that type of
language."
>> Yeah, this guy needs re-education. And I
don't mean any communist [__] I mean
like you need to do high school like
three more times
>> that they're trying to censor
uh or like the type of language they're
using to imply censorship among children
is crazy.
>> Mhm. Yeah. Again, I don't know if it was
for children, but like at the very
least, like the way that they told the
story, it was just like, "Holy cow, this
is like I listened to somebody play
through it after it was like brought
back up and I was just like, "This is
insane. I can't believe I just can't
believe that that people would think
that it was acceptable to like try and
pass that off." But again, it's
>> Brett Bongs. Bunch of
>> Brit bombs.
>> To be clear, it's it's unacceptable. It
is.
>> Okay, so back to back to Smaggle real
quick. just a commentary side community.
Yeah.
>> Uh a little side note that I'd like to
bring up for Smaggle specifically, I
just sent you another tweet was this
Twitter exchange that happened where uh
Smaggle was frankly raped by Colossal is
crazy.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Uh
in my defense because you know Smaggle
was
>> I don't even know if I can show [__]
app merch and [__] bro. specifically
Smaggle really don't have a backbone.
>> Yeah,
>> they don't have a stance.
>> He argues with Smaggle about his
allegations and [__]
>> Tear him down.
>> Dude, did you hear that, dude? He was
like struggling for words there. Um,
Smaggle is retweeting morality behind
when I first
I heard about like guess what, buddy?
surface level shitty content and uh
it ultimately he's not going to succeed.
I don't think so.
>> I don't care like either way. I just
think it's funny that cuz like uh you
know I hear about this guy who uses a
cat avatar and then I look up his name.
>> One of the first things that shows up is
a Turkey TomTom clip where Tom says,
"Yeah, I had this moderator and he told
me that he had heaped
in my server." And I was like, "Why
didn't you do that?" And he's like, "Oh,
because I wanted to mess with him." And
I'm just sitting there like, "Holy
[__] shit."
>> Yeah. But the funniest thing is uh after
getting uh raped by Colossal, he admits
that he was lying and then Colossal and
I always read this in his voices.
>> So you just said,
>> "I think contests that story." I think
contests that story
>> for no reason. Got it. Well done. Offer
still stands, but I've increased my rate
to $3 a word. Uh I don't offer this, you
stop showing.
>> It's It's not It's not necessarily uh
if you want to get really under his skin
and get really like like destroy his
arguments, you kind of have to play by
his rules, which are ridiculous and
debate perverted.
>> And who's
and it just makes the process four hours
longer than it really should be, which
is why my content deputy is so long,
honestly. It's cuz I have to play around
his little jungle
>> um to make an argument.
>> His jungle full of of scary spiders
because he lives in Australia.
>> It's 14 pages.
>> But uh wouldn't want to cause any
traumatic events for
>> sounds like Cameron lost. That's what it
sounds like to me.
>> He was basically like hitting them
during sex like [__] hard. There we
go.
>> As I know, there's been no alleging of
illegal action taken because all of
these women, as far as I know, were
>> that's just wrong.
>> Were above age and they all consented to
date him. I think the closest
Oh, we got no marital raping. We got a
tactical tempo fan
>> is like there is alleging that like I
don't know if it was beating or he was
just like way too harsh.
>> So, how do you date someone without
consent? Explain that one. Explain that
one to me. Morocco.
Explain that one to me, Morocco. How do
you date someone without consent? What
are we [__] saying here?
>> Yeah, during intercourse.
>> They're saying that like he was
basically like hitting them during sex
like [__] hard, which it's like and
then they're like, "It's beyond kink."
And it's like, well, it's like what is
what boundaries did you set up? Was he
going over boundaries? Was was he being
like a bad partner? And if it was so
bad, was it was it continuous?
Um, and then the other one was that he
apparently started filming mid [__]
>> Yes, that was the one that could have
been borderline in my personal opinion.
He's going to have to come out and
probably talk about that. I'd say maybe.
>> Yeah, I want to know what that's about.
But if it happens multiple times, then
to me it sounds like they never said no
and just were personally uncomfortable
with it without expressing [laughter]
that and we're learn he's probably
learning that with us or if he wasn't we
have no text to understand
>> words you just should always avoid
saying during these topics.
Number one, she didn't say no.
That's a phrase that should be generally
off limits. You should come up with I
understand in some circumstances there's
some way you want to phrase that.
Generally, though, avoid that phrasing
at least. And I'm going to be real, even
in this context, that's a pretty bad
meaning.
>> Correct me if I'm wrong. Um,
>> uh, I don't know. No. Oh yeah, we don't
really have a whole lot yet. I think
like we have a couple texts from him,
but none of them are like that.
>> Cam Nuggets is in chat.
>> Welcome.
Um, but no. Yeah, it's it is to my
knowledge and understanding that like we
it's it's a lot of speaking and then
there is some pictures like I saw the
pictures where like one of the girls was
texting him and he was like saying uh
the Amher stuff which I I think is him
just like messing.
>> Um but like outside of that I haven't
seen a whole lot yet. So I I mean like
you know if these girls want to continue
to drip cuz what's been going on is
they've been drip feeding stuff that
like went down on the farms and people
have just been asking questions and all
that kind of stuff.
>> Yeah. I just find it extremely
suspicious that this girl had um
screenshotted the Tinder match while
apparently not knowing uh who Tom was,
which I'm like, okay, that's a load of
[__] I also wonder if he ever did
ask to record. I think I think if he
didn't he should have and maybe they
said yes and then he
>> Wow. Wow. Brave take. I think if Tom
didn't ask to record sex before pulling
out his phone, he should have.
Thanks, Cam. Wow. You know, Cameron, I
got to agree with you on that one. I'll
give it to I'll give it to you there,
Cameron. I agree with you on that. Uh I
think Yeah, Cam Dougish just said it,
too. if they said yes, uh maybe
afterwards he just stopped asking
because he assumed it was going to be
implied consent, right? And maybe that
wasn't probably the best move or
whatever. I think he should address that
one specifically. I think that's like
the one that
>> could be kind of shitty. It's also not
like the unforgivable sin. uh if he was
well it could the big sweet the big
there's there's a set of circumstances
where I say okay come on man
>> like that's [__] you know
>> my personal opinion is you probably just
shouldn't record sex anyway because like
it'll come back to bite you
>> especially if you're in a position like
that
>> you know yeah my opinion has always
really just been uh don't take pictures
of yourself on the internet uh don't
record yourself or other people on the
internet. There's way too many
situations, destiny, uh where uh it's
going to come back and bite you even if
you think that you're in the right. Uh
when it in this day and age, women can
turn around and say, "Oh, I didn't give
consent." Even if they did give consent.
So, you know, it's just not worth it in
my personal opinion.
>> One of one of uh one of the reasons I
became friends with you is you said the
phrase, "The burden of proof is on the
accuser." And I'll always agree with
that.
>> Yes, it is. The burden of proof is on
the accuser. Also, chat, I will read
super chats here soon.
>> Wow. No one else agrees with that. Tom
also has like four play buttons,
probably more cuz you have Tom Dark
Live, Tom Dark, uh two for Tom Dark, and
then two for uh so he's got five at
least, and then Tom IRL. So, he might
have six play buttons,
>> right?
>> He's like Mr. Beast only with silvers.
>> And [laughter] she didn't notice for
seven months. That's a great point. Uh,
>> she's claiming to have not known he was
a YouTuber for 7 months.
>> Maybe they never she never went to his
house.
>> No, that's not what she's claiming.
>> I don't know. I don't know.
>> But she also screenshotted the match on
Tinder,
>> right? And my question,
>> she found out I believe after the first
date is her claim, right?
>> Would be
>> and still had that screenshot all of
this time later.
>> I My only thought
>> I agree that it's unlikely that she
didn't know who she who he was. I think
she knew who he was. That's why she
screenshotted it. But uh she does claim
that she knew after first date.
>> That's what for that would be I think
some women are weird and they screenshot
or take pictures of weird things. So
maybe it could be as simple as she took
a picture of somebody she matched with.
But like
>> Well, I could understand like doing that
and sending it to the girlies or
whatever, some gay [__] like that.
>> Yeah.
>> But to still have it after all of this
time is also like kind of like
>> Can I show this morale? Okay. Ralph's
showing evidence to vindicate himself.
This is Turkey Tom DMing Ralph saying,
"Gotcha. All right. Well, I'm willing to
kind of let bygones be bygones just
because I don't think he had malicious
intent." After I investigated a bit
myself, I found out the dude wasn't even
a pedophile. As per the girl's
explanation to me that he was 18 and she
was 16.
So, if Moral helped out a pedophile,
then Cameron F5 is a pedophile. maybe
not cleaning out the phone storage, but
to remember it to post on the Kiwi
Farms. And also, that's such an odd
thing that because that he would avoid
talking about it, she decided to post on
it there after learning about how bad it
apparently was.
>> Mhm.
>> Like, I feel like that's just such a
weird contradictory
statement.
I'm also not trying to pick a part to
like dunk on this girl. Something bad
actually happened.
>> Spondile about to make 15 tweets about
this. I won't be reading. I won't be
reading her, but I I think it's worth it
because Alex makes a tweet about it,
I'll read that. Okay. Alex tweets about
it, I'll read it. I'm not reading a
spawn tweet.
>> We've gotten a lot of nothing.
>> Mhm.
>> Sad. That is uh like I said to Boax,
this isn't the drama that people want it
to be.
>> No.
>> Which is another thing
>> I I I want to bring up. [laughter]
>> I I agree. My thought process is just
like uh as somebody who's covered drama
for two going on three years now like
there has to be some pre it's very rare
that like there is actual conc thank
youte stuff where it's just like okay
you can actually start to sink this
person um especi you know when I covered
the stuff with you I was like oh I feel
like that I need just a little bit more
you know there's a lot of weird sus
stuff and he definitely sounds like a
dumb teenager but outside of that and
I'll I'll What I will say with Tom is
just like um some of the stuff that's
alleged
>> it's cringe. It's cringe.
>> It is very cringe and it's going to be
made fun of and unfortunately uh like
what you kind of have to learn with this
kind of thing is as much as it sucks
that this stuff's public, people are
going to make fun of it and it's up to
you if you want to laugh along with it,
but you can't be like enraged by it as
well. You can be, but you can't like
>> you can't react.
>> Let that affect you like in a certain to
a certain extent.
>> Um
>> yeah.
>> Yeah. I'm Alex was the most recent
opener showcase I could think of.
Absolutely.
>> Quite funny that he made a video on
that.
>> I know. [laughter]
>> I'd say that was poor timing, but you
know what? He probably had that on a
timer. So like everybody that's [__]
on him, I was like, I don't know. Maybe
he actually
>> I literally I tune out a lot of what
he's saying cuz he sounds so [__]
disabled, dude.
>> People are gonna make fun of it. And
it's up to you if you want to laugh
along with it, but you can't be like
enraged by it as well. You can be, but
you can't like
>> you can't react.
>> Let that affect you like in a certain to
a certain extent.
>> Wow.
>> Um,
>> yeah.
>> Yeah. I was the most recent opener
showcase I could think of. Absolutely.
>> Quite funny that he made a video on
that.
>> I know. [laughter]
>> I'd say that was poor timing, but you
know what? He probably had that on a
timer. So, like everybody that's
[__] on him, I was like, I don't
know. Maybe he actually planned to have
that come out that day.
>> Now, I'm going to say this. No personal
>> game covering a good [__] instead of
Destiny. Is that is there even Destiny
[__] to cover? Oh, guys, I spoke to um
some I say I spoke to I brief I gave a
little bit of input while Jay spoke to
really some some woman that knows
Destiny or some [__] called into J
stream last night
and like had a total meltdown. And it
was really funny.
And she like as she's about to leave, I
ask her like, "Wait, Saturday night."
Like, "Wait, Friday night. Are you
drunk?" She's like, "Uh, okay. Thank
you. I'm going now." Sorry. Funny.
Well, uh, hey to Bobs as after this
tweet exchange that I'm that I'm about
to show you, um, he did DM and concede
and then briefly took down this
alternate Twitter of his and then put it
back up after making it impossible to
comment unless he follows you.
Uh, he tweeted, "When's the turkey ur
from
uh, Fatty Nick or whatever?" And
[laughter] then I said, "Why? Why didn't
Tom's friend hop on developing
accusations mid-stream with unreliable
evidence and outrageous claims? That's
[__] Boax, man. Come on.
>> Oh my gosh."
>> And he goes, "That's not what I said.
Why should he have to make a stream on
uncredible allegations from a BPD chick?
It's like at most cringe weird [__] with
little context. I'm not saying he
shouldn't. I'm saying he doesn't have
to. This isn't the crazy story that
people want it to be."
>> Yeah.
>> And that's ultimately what my take is on
it. I don't think it's the crazy story
that Chud Logic necessarily wants it to
be. Even though for whatever reason,
like didn't he have this thing uh last
New Year?
>> It is a crazy story. It's just not like
the the most damning stuff isn't proven.
It's a crazy story
>> where he was trying to get a one up on
Tom during a New Year's stream with the
whole Destiny stuff that didn't break.
Oh, [laughter]
>> dude.
>> Cameron is the one guy who thinks like
Tommy C.
>> Crazy. And he's just as dented.
>> And then I think so. I think what what
what went on is like he
>> and then he tried to defend himself
afterward. Oh, there's nothing wrong. Me
and Tom are great friends. Me and Tom
are fine. And now he's taking a victory
lap.
>> Guys, it feels like they've just gotten
into like the actual discussion that I
should actually be here for, but I was
just about to throw some food in
>> over time as if they've hated each other
for years. I don't know. This guy just
seemed duplicitous as [__] And I really
used to like Chud logic and it sucks to
say that
>> Chud said that he hated Tom for years.
>> No, he No, no, but he's No, but he's
acting like it.
>> He's taking this victory l I just want
to make sure that's
>> What is he even talking about? Where is
that? Where is that? Show me that.
>> So that's okay. Fair enough. [laughter]
>> If I did say that, I meant to say it's
as if he's hated Tom for years.
Uh, ICE needs to consider deporting
autistics. Well, here's the thing. Boax
lives in Canada. You can't deport him
from Canada. Canada will deport him in
Canada's going to probably take in the
people that ICE deports.
>> But yeah, I do want to make it clear on
this thread specifically that Bob did
reach out and concede his point
privately.
>> Oh, did he?
>> Uh, and I'm comfortable saying that
>> because
he won't do it publicly. [laughter]
But there's no hard feelings. There's no
hard feelings.
>> I can't remember why, but Boax blocked
me a long time ago. I can't even
remember what I said. I It might have
just been
>> He unblocked me.
>> He I blocked him because I made a
Manshee. He blocked me cuz I made a
Manche joke and then unblocked me.
>> Yeah, that's funny. It's really funny.
>> And follows me. But I have I I don't I
don't have anything personal wrong with
Boax. I I think he can make good content
if he wants to. I think he has to get
off his ass and make good content and
stop worrying about what other people
think about him. Like
>> I totally agree.
>> I don't give any advice to Bax. It's
that I I think he has the ability to
make good content and he needs to get
off his ass and [__] do it.
>> Yeah. No, I agree. I agree. I agree. The
big problem with Bobs is just like after
everything what happened, it's just like
gone downhill and it's just like Boax,
stop streaming cuz nobody wants to
listen to what you have to say. Just
make the tweets and put them out there.
That's all people want, you know?
Well, it I think it's the fact that I
>> commentary here.
>> Yeah,
>> I I haven't kept up with Lex at all
because like he's never really somebody
that was interesting about him from that
drama.
>> So, is Lex like
>> and obviously I don't care either way.
Is he trans now or is he just
crossdressing now?
>> Uh that whole thing is I I'm honestly
with that I like all parties they really
don't like. Lick is uh Lix isn't a
crossdresser or trans. He said he's just
trying new things. I think
>> that's what they all say. Well, no, he
is a crossdresser. Okay.
No, he is absolutely crossdressing.
That's what that is.
I'm sorry. I've looked at those images.
He is crossdressing.
That's what's happening in those images.
That's what they all say. Chud's stream.
Now, Chud's coverage of lyrics is
admittedly funny. Um, the problem is
it's just again it's kind of duplicitous
the way he's going about it. And I feel
like one day he's going to be
duplicitous to the wrong person. Cough.
Nicholas Dioro.
>> He literally they literally even said
Kai did an L cosplay and he did Misa.
They said that
>> and I believe that's currently happening
from what I've been told. Yeah, I I
heard I have I don't have the tweet on
me, but like I saw that like there was a
thing say where Nick was like, "Oh,
yeah, I had a falling out with Chud and
I'm just sitting here like, "Oh, is this
your first one?" I swear you probably
that's happened before in the past.
>> No, I I don't know. I don't I don't know
why. Like the the the whole community of
creatants that Shud has spawned have
>> legit, dude. Spicy chat rape trauma yet
again. more spicy chat rape drama.
>> Bit of stain. Yeah. And [laughter] it's
me want nothing to do with commentary
and just want to make my own lane.
>> I mean that's judge y'all from the
sidelines.
>> Make his own lane by um
making videos where he regurgitates what
Nicholas Durio says on his streams.
>> I'm like I like to backseat game in the
commentary community.
>> Oh [laughter] wow. You're cool, bro.
>> Backseat game.
Yeah, he's mad he got ran out.
Literally, the seething at or the
seething at Smaggle, the spicy chat rape
trauma just like it's not even subtle.
It's not even subtle.
>> You [__] suck.
>> I mean, that's fair. That's fair. That's
fair. No, I I mean, like, it's really
been interesting to watch how commentary
has kind of just evolved over the last
couple of years. Like I it kind of went
from Augie's thing when and then when
Auggie disappeared it all kind of just
fell apart and now um Nick is streaming
to his 3 to 5k people whenever he's
talking about um
>> [__]
>> I think I think Nick right now is
probably industry standard for um
commentary streaming.
>> You think so?
>> Yeah. Because
>> I feel like
it is a as as someone who has streamed
for several years. It is a difficult
thing to multitask
uh focus on a video, provide uh
additional gameplay since he doesn't
like to use a facecam and uh still be
engaged with what he's talking about and
provide uh point.
>> What is Nick? Sorry,
I'm going to have an aneurysm.
Nicorio
engaged with the content and providing
poignant commentary. There's no way
you're about to say this with a straight
face
>> video, provide uh additional gameplay
since he doesn't like to use a face cam
[snorts] and uh still be engaged with
what he's talking about and provide uh
poignant commentary, which I think he
typically does.
>> [__] kill me.
>> Uh even though even if I don't always
agree with it, it's still like it's
there's still thought there and there's
still like reason
>> uh that I can understand there. He has
actual logic with what he says. I would
say most of the time. Yeah, I would
agree there.
>> Yeah. And I and I think he um and I
think that's why I respect him a lot
just like as a as a fellow creator. Um
but uh and and it's something that I
just don't think other commentary
streamers have been able to match. I
think Tom I Tom
>> I would stomp this [__] [__] I
would stomp this fat [__]
I would stomp any of these [__]
retards on any of the merits of any of
the arguments, any of the criticisms
I've made of any of these people. I
would stomp the [__] life out of them
in a conversation and it's not even
close. That's why they don't do it. It's
so [__] annoying.
>> Dark Live was probably the closest
second. I think
>> Tom didn't stream very much though, did
he?
>> No, but he he he had like a a frequent
stream schedule for about a year in
2024.
>> Yeah.
>> Um that I thought that was really
entertaining for me that like kind of
got me pulled me back into commentary
[music] the commentary community. Yeah.
>> So,
>> that's fair. That's fair.
>> But with these allegations, I just feel
like uh a lot of snakes are coming out
of the grass and I feel like
it's going to become a little bit of a
game of whack-a-ole.
>> Mhm.
>> Um you're going to see on a much bigger
scale than what you did with uh easy
example for me.
>> Make another video on this guy. I'm so
mad. Um
the the snakes in the grass like really
popped their heads out.
>> Walkie's home video
>> with you. You were a smaller creator.
>> You were a smaller creator. You were
>> Exactly. So it was
>> You weren't a nobody, but you were
basically a nobody. Tom is like And Tom
is the guy of over all of
>> Exactly. I was a nobody. And then I then
I kind of got into uh not not as much of
a nobody anymore out of it. Um, and
that's just because they kept making
content,
>> right?
>> Uh, but the fact that they tried to
steamroll over me and I was able to duck
my head under the steamroller,
>> dude. Literally, it is like a permanent
black mark on your reputation. That's
why you're so mad at everyone. Yes.
Everyone's aware that any content
creator can just post their allegations.
The reason you're so mad at Ogie and
Smaggle and everyone else is because you
know you This is the thing. This is
this is a lie commentary YouTubers will
tell you is that it's basically and this
is like the biggest cope ever that Camar
and Dior both run with. And it's it's
sad that this is their cope. It's sad
that this they think this is a good
cope, but to them it's all about the
money. It's all about their views. It's
sad that that's their cope in of itself,
but the fact that they lean on this to
avoid confronting the fact that they are
desperately tied up in their image and
reputation and wanting to be like, you
know,
the cabal
is like next level sickening for the
lack of self-awareness it displays. And
the fact they think other people are
actually falling for it is crazy.
Yeah.
>> Uh, I feel like I kind of see this
coming and I see where this is going and
I know Tom's going to be fine out of it
if uh, you know, God willing, these
allegations are false and I
>> I Yeah,
>> pretty I I my DAR on this is pretty
good. I'm pretty
not too worried.
>> You're not too worried? My Yeah, my
thought process is is what right now
they're very serious. Um, and but like
unless these women like post anything of
substance.
>> Well, no, I I I think it could go either
way. My personal opinion is unless these
women post actual like substantive stuff
that actually warrants like some sort of
like reply. Um, the greatest advice I
would give Tom is if this is fake, don't
address it. Just move on and people will
forget about it. Because that's how it
works. Like literally, I have seen
YouTubers who have scammed their
audiences disappear from the internet,
then come back 6 months later and guess
what? They get a brand new audience or
people forget and they don't care
anymore. So, it's just like if these
things have no merit or no substance, he
can just move on and people will forget
about it in a couple of months time cuz
that's how that works. The only people
that will remember it are the commentary
people.
>> Uh
it's going to be hypocritical as [__] uh
as I'm on a VTuber stream. The VTuber
drum is gay as [__]
>> It is. No, I mean like it is. That's
part of take it seriously. I never I can
never take it seriously.
>> You shouldn't take it seriously cover
it.
>> And uh I think less I I think the best
VTuber is burnt peanut. So
>> you piss off a lot of people saying
that.
>> I really don't care.
>> Uh
[laughter]
[gasps]
so that's that's my take.
If you enjoy Vtubing, that's fun. If you
enjoy VTubers, go for it. That's your
thing. Not my personal cup of tea.
>> No, that's completely fine. Like
Idubbbz, I'm not every I know it's not
everybody's cup of tea.
>> Yeah, [laughter]
I know. I'm not everyone's cup of tea.
>> Oh my god.
>> Something like that. Something like
that.
>> Jewish.
>> Um, no. Unironically, it's horrible.
Just to give you an idea of how gay some
of the VTuber drama is, there was a
female VTuber. She's like, "Get back to
right now." Where's the Tom discussion?
>> Is people found out that she's not
white, she is
style,
>> anti-Jew in like the silly way. Uh she
was like,
>> this VTuber was a like chud like uh
VTuber. Not like Chudlo Logic, but just
like Chud in like the term Chud. She was
like anti Chud.
>> How long is this? like she was anti-Jew
in like the silly way. Uh she was like
very racist towards anything that wasn't
white and like she was just like she was
just like uh oh my gosh my oh she is
racist too kind of thing and everybody
gave her money because of that.
Elephant. Yes, Elfen. What ended up
happening is that people found out that
she's not white. She is Ukrainian and
Pakistani. So she's not white. And that
kind of like ruined a lot of her
reputation cuz she built herself off of
saying, "Oh, I [__] hate anybody that
isn't white." and uh or at least
partially. Um and then to own the Chuds,
she came out and said that like some
pictures that people got of her when she
was young or when she was underage and
she was like the thing I
>> autistic rambling about YouTube drama.
>> Where's the Tom? Come on.
>> Cuz he was one of the he he kind of like
he made the the the [__] hat stop
gooning. That's like literally like one
of the
>> That's just a little weird. Um
>> it's a form of gooning.
>> It is. It is.
>> Like constantly beating off like Yeah,
sure. I mean I But I then again, why do
you make the sex tapes?
>> Right. Right. Right. Right. My opinion
is like I do believe that. I do believe
it. And the reason why I believe it, and
I I I briefly talked about this with you
in DMs, but I like have been observing
that a lot of people, and I I I think
that there's like a healthy relationship
that you can have with yourself, with
your with your partner, or just like
overall in general. And I think that the
people that are very like they're they
they act very icky about like intimacy
or just like normal human human nature,
those are the people that I feel like
are most likely to have weird things
hidden behind the scenes that we don't
know about. And so like when it comes to
Tom and this this stuff, I'm like, well,
if it's true, I mean, I guess I kind of
see it because he was one of the he he
kind of like he made the the the [__]
hat stop gooning. That's like literally
like one of the big If true, it's one of
the biggest projections ever. Exact.
Yeah. It's just like one of the biggest
projections ever. If it's true,
>> I was a huge fan of the stop going
movement. Right.
>> Um
>> and I I'd be a little heartbroken to
learn that our leader was a Gooner the
whole time.
>> Mhm.
>> Um
>> and I'll tell you this, like I think I
wore this hat during the while covering
the Destiny like child porn allegations.
Am I allowed to say that?
>> Yeah, you Yeah. Uh, just call it cam or
cam.
>> Okay. So,
>> accusations.
>> Perfect. That works too.
>> Um,
>> getting a lot of use out of that uh Go
XLR there, aren't you?
>> Oh, yeah. Always.
>> Oh.
>> Um,
you don't like the rim shot?
>> Oh, no. I think I I think it's just
fine. I just found it funny. I remember
when you told me you got it and I was
like, "Make sure you download that third
party patch from the devs that are still
playing around with it afterwards."
>> I know. I know. I love Mega Explorer, by
the way.
>> It's fant It's a It's a It's a very
inexpensive tool for professionals. I
like it.
>> Right. Right. It basically if if you if
you have any like audio experience, um
if you're going to spend like $200 on a
Scarlet or like a Focus right, you might
as well just get a Go XLR.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I the only reason why I tell
people not to like go for that is
because um
>> it's depreciated.
>> Yeah. And you have to like go through
again you have to know where you're
where you're looking to get the patch so
that you can continue to use it outside
of its unsupported nature cuz it's
unsupported now. So
>> I mean I I don't really have a problem
evils.
>> I don't think that's I think that's a
more traditional take that people are
adopting now. Well, I suck.
>> Let's move on to [music] Dior.